in this video I want to talk about the
lives of Frankish women who lived during
the Carolingian dynasty and the eighth
and ninth century so you can see here in
blue the Carolingian dynasty and the
Carolingian dynasty ruled over much of
the former territory of the western
roman empire after the fall of the
Western Roman Empire Europe was
controlled by many decentralized
kingdoms including the Carolingian
dynasty and in this context powerful
clans and families became increasingly
important this undoubtedly had effects
on the lives of women who were often the
heads of these households and who helped
manage the complex economy of these
clans so I want to look at a primary
source that might give us some insight
into the lives of women at this time so
I want to read something written by du
Oda the Duchess consort of Sept amania
and the countess consort of Barcelona do
Oda was a noblewoman and in the excerpt
we'll read she is addressing her son so
she wrote a manual called the liber menu
Alice which was meant to teach her son
certain values so let's read it together
and talk about it the purpose of this
was to instruct her son on proper
behavior I'm not reluctant to teach you
as well as I can how you should fear
love and be faithful in all ways to
Bernard your Lord and father both when
you are with him and when you are apart
on this matter you have a teacher and
the wisest authority namely Solomon he
chastens and advises you my son saying
God has honored the father who
flourished in his children and again he
who honors his father shall rejoice in
his own children and shall live a longer
life he who obeys his father will give
heavenly solace to his mother and he who
honors his father is like one who lays
up many good treasures he who fears the
Lord honors his parents you then my son
honor your father and prayed diligently
for him so that you may reach an
advanced age and live on
earth a long time so if we look at this
excerpt we can pull out some information
about the society and which duo delived
first of all she's writing this in order
to instruct her son and this is really
representative of the way in which women
at this time were important as the heads
of household and important in educating
their children particularly their
children's moral education and as we see
here she talks a lot about certain
Christian values so she says that his
wisest authority and his teacher is
Solomon who's a biblical figure so he or
she is referring to Christian ideas and
she even notes that God has honored the
father who flourished in his children
and she uses these biblical references
in order to advise her son to be a
better son to his father and she really
emphasizes this respect and love towards
the father now why this emphasis well it
makes sense that she's emphasizing the
father because around this time patron
lineage became more important and patron
lineage is basically descent that goes
through the line of the father and this
might seem like something that's always
been around but this was a shift from
these broader extended clan into a
smaller family unit where there is a
father and a mother and children rather
than so many other family members so for
du Oda to enforce this respect and
deference towards the father is
perfectly in line with this value of a
smaller family unit and these families
were very important especially these
powerful families because they were the
fundamental social unit in Frankish
society so to summarize some of the
insights that we can gain by looking at
this excerpt mothers played key roles
and households particularly as the moral
educators of their children the ones who
are responsible for making sure they're
chill
children understood the moral ideas of
their society and secondly that Pedro
lineage really defines smaller family
units and within that fathers and
mothers were important but in this
excerpt duo does really reinforcing
their respect and deference towards the
father and through this excerpt we can
also see the importance of Christian
values which are really informing the
advice that she gives to her son